[Music]
I think about death all the time and
it's not a morbid sullen exercise for me
it's this becomes easier as older you
get because friends start dying family
members die and you realize this is not
an indefinite lease yes you have or that
it is at least you don't own it yeah it
is at least yes and that having the I
don't want to call it time pressure but
awareness of that impermanence for me I
find this might sound strange but like
greatly encouraging because it drives a
sense of urgency yeah or at least time
sensitivity to a lot of my decisions and
so that's on one hand surprising this
fleeting yeah on renewable resource that
is time and realizing that doesn't
matter how much money you're willing to
pay on your deathbed you're not gonna be
able to buy back more time right and
then simultaneously
I guess meditating is the best way to
put it or contemplating how little a lot
of this matters or all of it meant yeah
in so much as you know as neva wat once
said to me is like yeah we're just a
bunch of monkeys on the spinning rocky
and spending time this sounds so
highfalutin but whatever reading about
the cosmos or contemplating as believe
it was IDI cook an incredible memory
competitive champion and entrepreneur
memorizes his company M EMR ISE and
coach also writer had said to me he
would and BJ BJ Miller who's a hospice
care physician I think did something
very similar but they would look at say
the Stars and imagined
that it's possible and I'm not an
astrophysicist so maybe this isn't
possible about that it's possible that
the star you are seeing is in fact light
that is hitting your eye from a star
that no longer exists
yeah right and to just sort of
contemplate that yeah you're freaking
out because you have some problem with
Amex right or there's some disagreement
and it's like somebody badmouth you at
work or whatever it is you're right okay
to number one or number two on the New
York Times bestseller list or you know
all the things that who cares yeah all
dust yes
as our friend Marcus woods yes like all
dust I get nobody gives a [ __ ] right
like it's not even you in the future
will give a [ __ ] it's yeah it's it's
it's all going to be it's just
completely irrelevant and so holding
those two in my mind has been a practice
and I do think about death a lot and
there was a person featured in I think
it was tribe mentors Moonee Valley who's
involved very heavily involved with
cryptocurrency and very very smart guy
might I maybe better put blockchain very
smart guy and it's funny to me how
certain things stick and certain things
don't stick or certain things have like
a time-release right so I read this
knows I go that's interesting yeah and
then months later it's resurfaced and
I've thought about it a lot since which
was he'll he will routinely ask himself
when he's over whelmed or feeling
scattered and how much would I pay to
relive this experience like 20 years
from now 30 years from now 40 years from
now and I'm paraphrasing yes that's not
not not perfectly stated but and I think
about that we're all be if I think about
the experiences that I would pay the
most for and I'm being honest with
myself it's it's not the professional
successes
or the glamour shots it's usually
something very simple right like it's a
moments of stillness and quiet now he's
said wake waking up in bed with my
girlfriend on a beautiful sunny day and
like patting the padding the bed and
having my dog jump up right having a
little snuggle fest it's very it sounds
so cheesy like the 20 year old Tim would
just be vomiting all by himself right
now but nonetheless 20 20 roll Tim is
pretty miserable [ __ ] so I feel like
I've improved on that front and asking
yourself alright if I were 80 and like
Molly has long since passed away maybe
my wife has passed away how much would I
pay for them yeah and that really to me
is part and parcel of the valuing of
time these slivers of experience as more
valuable than making a speculative
decision about earning more in the
future based on doing something that
takes you away from those people
you